hello and welcome to this video playing
it was a quick move so another French
exchange show me if you know how to play
against it visually fine
this move is actually quite interesting
it's basically never played but it has
some interesting ideas because f-4s
sorry c2fo see form you can actually
consider to take on b1 and play the
check on before simply to trade off many
pieces and then play against a QP it's
not too bad and long story short this
move is actually strongest it's a little
bit odd to to offer a trade but you
develop yeah exactly
now they play all their plays see six
and let me think about it no I check
first I have to check first Queen e7 I
go Bishop b3 and black will notice that
he will be stuck in the center unless he
plays this one yeah which is a little
bit crazy okay anyway so how do we
attack this long castles is just not a
great idea but how to attack it can go C
4 B 3 C 4 interesting
before b5 is also certainly an option
listen I don't want to put a knight on
2d to where it looks bad
let's go see for ya
here I was thinking b3 just I want to
take with the pawn and open everything
up and taking on v3 is a bit crazy so he
didn't do it but this is not bad in
terms of development okay
d5 form okay and if I was actually not
so good so whoopsie one I need to get
the queen of the of the e-file okay he
actually allows we should f4 check 95
this is this is most logically I just
open everything up
I can I underestimated the capture with
the Ruger a little bit I have to admit I
mean this is definitely dangerous but
probably not decisive rook e1 and
threatening Queen takes d5 but okay
that's a very simple
rookie Rookie one it's not so easy to
suggest you mean I have six maybe
okay yeah let's go here Ruby one
hmm I'm not totally convinced here that
what I did is right yeah honestly it
looks like the black is black is
somewhat okay which you shouldn't be
yeah I played this badly I just played
it badly
I shouldn't sacrifice probably on with
d5
still never have some initiative
indisposition but it's nothing nothing
great at all
okay ff7 is attacked so I don't quite
see how he comes at prom he cannot do it
Queen takes c4 is the most normal move a
castle goes for developing
not too happy with everything yeah it's
just not I'm just not don't like what I
did in this game it was some was not
right and there are tactics here like a
Bishop f2 and and thinks that that you
know some some tactical idea based on f2
with the rukon evade my ideas 96 but you
can probably send this off and he takes
it but that I feel it's not a good idea
firm now everything hangs the knight c7
much you have 97 or such a disaster to
be honest but we're so Luke going
nowhere
I have a double check doesn't doesn't
get much he just resigned I don't know
why I just don't know why what is the
threat why am I just plain stupid no
root yet I mean I'm better according to
the comp but I'm not winning
yeah this is this is good for white
absolutely and I analyzed this quite a
bit
queeny's six I think was my main line
anyway he casted Longwood which is
basically crazy so this B 3 is actually
aligned that the engine likes here and
and now d5 of course
ah that's too bad you have to play ah
this is really bad D played I think this
is like very natural just take it but
this is obviously very strong the moment
where he has no no Knight here or here
so he has to take with the pawn allow
the capture or play c5 all of which are
terrible yeah I probably c5 is
relatively best but now your position is
the complete wreck it was the game over
one but anyway I could have killed him
this this and d5 via d5 was just yeah I
wanted to punish this stuff with
energetic play but probably it is not
good and it is not good I'm sorry I'm
still hugely better with any normal move
like a form yeah it makes a lot of sense
trying to push all the way this the
center before okay when you cannot
cancel long in that position that's just
not going to work I came and now I'm
basically fishing here with a pawn down
and c4 Knight f6 one Queen before yeah
95 trying to be active Bishop c5 is the
best
okay now the ng reconsiders but it
doesn't give black an advantage at least
this this of this and now there's a
suggestion in the chat box if hook g4
was a possibility you only see that of
course after the game deform you know
yeah and exactly this is the problem
yeah yes so after the capture I'm a
better well for the moment but rook c8
and why exactly is this black reasoning
and there's just nothing going on i I
understand that I probably am better
with the active pieces but I would have
just able to just played Bishop d3 which
is one of the engines top choices you
cannot win material for a limb I mean
you can check here and repeat in some
way and okay King say doesn't move but
this yeah this doesn't let anything even
King said I think it's possible
yeah currently these are two pieces
hanging you can take but there's nothing
going on him
there's just nothing going on I don't
know he probably he saw some ghosts I
would have played Bishop g3 and simply
continue this they have this idea still
in my pocket and then maybe try to
invade on the yeah like in seven or
something yeah now I'm really I'm a bit
angry that I didn't play d5 hands Knight
takes III is a very human decision like
okay and they give you the pawn you take
it but we fight this killing black it's
just killing black and it's not
difficult it's not a difficult move okay
thanks for watching